the director of kick-ass takes on x-men
here we go
x-men first class now I personally love
the first two x-men movies I mean they
were great they were intriguing there
were good personal stories as well as
exciting action movies x-men 3 and x-men
origins Wolverine No
so two good x-men movies two crappy
x-men movies x-men first class is going
to tip the scale one way or the other
so x-men first class is like the genesis
of the x-men movies it's how Charles
Xavier met magneto magneto met Charles
Xavier delves into a lot more of
Magneto's past which is really cool
because you know that first shot in the
first x-men movie where Magneto's a
little kid his mom gets taken away and
he freaks out and he bends the gate that
scene is in this movie like almost
shot-for-shot so right there I was like
alright this is a prequel to the first
movie straight up so now magneto before
he was magneto Erik Lehnsherr he's on a
quest for revenge he wants to kill Kevin
Bacon but I love Footloose let's dance
and then we see Charles Xavier which is
really funny to see because he's this
really smart guy but he's a lot younger
in this one so he's out drinking and
having a good time it was really cool to
see professor axe like in his youth
Michael Fassbender was really good as
Erik Lehnsherr that's for sure but I
can't say he stole the show because
James McAvoy was just as good as Charles
Xavier it's like a team effort yin and
yang thing to have going on that's how
it should be and it's cool to see
Charles Xavier and Erik Lehnsherr have
this friendship but you know erik
lensherr first and foremost is on his
quest for revenge and of course Xavier
wants to talk him out of it and it's
good and Kevin Bacon as Sebastian Shaw
Kevin Bacon was awesome in this movie
now he's no stranger to being a bad guy
but it's almost like he's a joke you
know like Chuck Norris jokes and the six
degrees of Kevin Bacon Kevin Bacon in
this movies like yeah six degrees of
this I'm a badass villain screw you guys
let's dance and it takes place in the
60s so there's a threat of the Cuban
Missile Crisis all sorts of stuff which
is nuclear holocaust and you know death
the stakes have never been higher before
there were any other stakes because it's
a prequel and it's up to Professor
Xavier to put together a team that's
gonna save the world yeah we don't want
him to fail all right honestly speaking
x-men first class it was okay I can't
even keep a straight face it was
actually really awesome
x-men first class reminded me why I like
the first two so much because it's such
a personal story with the main
characters it's also a really exciting
movie it's like everything you want a
summer movie cool action cool characters
cool dialogue - like Xavier is actually
kind of funny at times I'd never really
seen that side of him that was awesome
and speaking of action there's this
villain
this movie named Azazel this guy's
hardcore he's doing stuff like hitting
guys and teleporting and then
teleporting behind him and hitting him
in the air i mean choosing to fight
Azazel is like choosing to fight
scorpion and Mortal Kombat when he's
being controlled by a Japanese kid just
don't do it you're gonna lose guy was
hardcore guy was badass now as much as
they keep this movie in line to be a
prequel to the x-men movies honestly not
counting Wolverine in x-men 3 like there
is no way I can tie to x-men origins or
x-men 3 you know that scene in the
beginning of x-men 3 when Xavier and
Magneto go up to jeans doorstep probably
not happening but there are some
discrepancies with this movie in the
first two movies - but all in all good
acting good script good direction and
good characters and good action I really
don't know what I was expecting going
into x-men first class but I'd like to
think that it's this in fact I think I
actually like this movie more than Thor
and I really like Thor and it's
happening x-men first class is awesome
tacular
I have given away more awesome tacular
in the last month and like all of last
year feels like that anyway so what are
your favorite x-men movies did you see
x-men first class what did you think of
it comment below let me know and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
let's dead